eli where does that great story begin
for you
oh boy i don't know that's a hard
question to start with
where does it begin do you mean
something that i'm writing or something
that i'm experiencing something that i'm
watching
could be both you could maybe think of a
movie that really uh
you know sort of drew you into your love
for film yeah i mean i guess it's not
necessarily this
it's not necessarily the story that um
engages me it's more the point of view i
think point of view is the most
important thing
um because i think that
we tell a lot of the same stories
[Music]
but it is um it is the way that they are
told
the way that they are executed that
makes them interesting or makes them
unique
um and i think that's the thing that i
respond to and that's the thing that i'm
most conscious of
is what is my point of view in trying to
tell a story
what am i trying to get at that's
different
than someone else's approach to the
story so
it's that it's the their view of the
world and that point of view
can be political it can be apolitical it
can be
um philosophical
it's um it's the uniqueness of the of
the perspective
of the person telling the story that i
think is the the most critical
yeah like if you think about uh reality
tv and the dating shows and then you
take something like sherman's march
i know that's going back a few years but
no it's a great film
it's excellent and just seeing the guys
i was it's ross and ross okay uh
his his like hesitance and his falling
in love
and then falling in love with someone
new and then being in this small town
and all the expectations with that
and then you could see the exact same
thing and we'll leave the name of the
shows out
but something about the way that ross
did it was so natural
i could have watched another three hours
of it yeah i mean the way he's
he is not afraid to let um
his intention devolve um and i mean i
even wouldn't even have to talk about a
different subject matter you could
certainly
i'm sure there have been multiple films
or television shows that have been made
about
sherman's march that are just a kind of
straight what we might call expository
retelling of the history right
and so um
those may have value or may not have
value but i think what makes
um that film um
sort of so memorable memorable is
because that approach he's not afraid to
let
this that's going to be about oh i meant
this other girl today
you know and also he lets um
uh one scene from that it's really
interesting i haven't thought about that
film in a long time but you bring
up one scene when i think of that film
that stands out is there's two women in
the kitchen talking about
you know we talking about civil war and
they lost but when that war
when it comes again we're going to be
ready for it this time or something like
that
and so he's um he's still delving into
the history he's still delving
into the sort of cultural wounds
that are there that are present but also
telling this great really funny really
unexpected that's
that's absolutely a great example of a
kind of uniqueness of point of view
um that you would not expect when you're
watching um
a movie that's supposedly about
sherman's march why it's three hours
long yeah and you're like i could take
another three hours of this it's so good
yeah
yeah no he's great he's really
interesting um he's an interesting guy
he's just
he's a fun guy to listen to um yeah and
sorry what expository can you just
explain so expository is like
um bill nichols is this um he's actually
a former professor of mine he was up at
san francisco state and
um uh he was at one time considered one
of the foremost
authorities maybe he still is i don't
know on documentary film and so he
broke down what he called the modes of
documentary film
um and the different their different
approaches to trying to find the
their notion of truth and one of them is
what's called expository an expository
mode so an expository mode is
a mode that believes in a kind of
absolute truth and tries to just relay
facts to the audience members so that
those facts might come through
um title cards that give us factual
information it might
come through in a sort of authoritative
voiceover or someone is giving you
this is when this happened this is what
this is going on but it is a
it's a treatment of the documentary
world and this notion of truth
as absolute and the film's job is to
deliver
those truths through those facts to you
via different techniques or talking head
interviews
for instance you get an expert to come
in and say this is what happened this is
why it happened all that sort of stuff
and
um so you could absolutely see a film a
documentary about sherman's
sermons march that takes that kind of
tact where
here's a historian historian's going to
talk about it and we'll give you some
voice over
and we'll give you some title cards
that'll give you the facts of when this
happened and when that happened
whereas um
mcelwee it's much more subjective it
might even be called what we
what nichols calls performative where
it's all about the personal it's all
about the subjective
um so yeah that's that's um
again i think that's what makes that
it's so interesting
was that some of what was done with 60
minutes i know i'm dating myself with
that one but i can remember it
as a style yeah absolutely yeah you know
or if you
i mean if you look at if you look at uh
sort of documentaries especially from
the 40s and 50s
that's the stuff that kind of dominated
that kind of expository style or even
something like march of the
penguins like is to use somewhat more
contemporary example
um no no no no i'm not
picking on you i'm myself i'm like okay
let me think of something here
um uh you know that there
is we're going to teach you facts here's
facts about
penguins and here's facts about how
penguins mate and their whole cycle what
they do throughout the year
and we're going to use morgan freeman's
voice to give you that information
and that way there's something about
selecting morgan freeman knowing that
the audience
is going to trust him right he's going
to deliver this factual information and
the audience will take it as
facts as the truth you know that's a
very expository style
which is way different than like the
film i mentioned before
um turn on the camera stories we tell
sarah paulie's movie
which is a really really interesting use
of a kind of performative style
where she does these reenactments but
you don't know that the reenactments
when you're watching them
and she's she's very much throughout the
course of the film
questioning the notion of what the truth
is
here she's trying to retell the story of
how of her family essentially
and there's also an extreme danger with
that because you could think back to
like propaganda films
yeah of the 40s and 30s and things like
that
yeah well i mean like uh you get into um
you do you get into question notions of
what is the truth but
um this here you get into ethical sort
of dilemma of
um what your role is as a documentary
filmmaker and
what um what you owe
i guess what you're supposed to try to
achieve some
would say in this kind of 6 60-minute
style that we're trying to
to delve into this kind of the absolute
truth and trying to figure that out
whereas others um might say that there's
no way to do that it's impossible
there's no way to sort of remove
yourself
one of the ways i if i'm lecturing on
documentary film one of the things that
i'll talk about
is how it's impossible to remove bias
um there's no such thing as sort of um
an unmediated film meaning you
are a documentary film you can't
remove your own perspective no matter
how hard you try
the example i i'll give is you know if i
if i decide that i'm going to make a
film about long beach city college
students right
um that's what i've decided i'm going to
do and there's like 30 000 students that
attend this school there's no way i can
talk to all 30 000 students
so i'm just going to talk to this class
of 80 kids
80 students but even talking to 80
students is too difficult so i'm just
going to take the first two rows which
is like 15
students and i'm going to talk to those
15 students and
when i'm doing those those interviews i
discover that this student over here is
not interesting on camera at all they're
boring so i can't use them i've got to
cut them out but this student
over here is really interesting so she's
going to be all over my movie
because i think she's saying all kinds
of interesting things and it aligns with
what i think is
is um possibly the um
proper perspective about being a long
beach city college student so then i
pose this question to them
where's the first time i showed my bias
by choosing the one interesting student
long before that i showed my bias when i
decided to make a movie about long beach
city college students
because as soon as i just made that
choice as soon as i said that i'm going
to make a
film about long beach city college
students i decided not to make a film
about
donald trump the automobile cats
whatever like there's a perspective
right there i'm saying that this is
interesting this is
newsworthy this should be a film i have
just indicated a bias right there
um and so there's no way to separate
your point of view or your perspective
or your way of seeing the world
once because you're making choices
immediately when i just decide to pick
up the camera and shoot something i've
made a choice
um so i i i always think that those
films a film like stories we tell a film
like sherman's march um
the stuff that werner herzog doesn't
like grizzly man
those films tend to be for me or aaron
morris's
documentary work tend to be the most
interesting because they're the ones
that are acknowledging
um that this truth is out here and it's
elusive and i don't know if it actually
exists and we can grab it or not all i
can do is
present my point of view and this is all
very slippery
i don't know that feels that feels more
honest to me
than here's the truth we're gonna give
you the truth
of the expository style um i mean
there's all kinds of people who do stuff
with
with observational documentary like
someone like frederick weissman
is just masterful or the measles
brothers before they died
were great at that stuff
was there a period in your life where
you really wanted to understand story
and so you just started consuming all
types of films
um i mean it wasn't because i wanted to
con
understand stories just i was interested
in movies like i wanted to just watch
movies
you know it wasn't necessarily because
i'm like oh i need to
figure out how they tell them i mean i i
grew up
i grew up in an area where there's not
film culture necessarily
and it was pre-digital revolution the
internet existed but
i didn't have the internet at the time
um you grew up on a farm i grew up on a
farm
and um and so
i i do remember at some point
there was i was more interested in like
screenplay structure or um even
screenplay format
because i i had you know as a teenager i
bought a couple of scripts from like uh
was it barnes and noble would we have
like borders i don't know one of those
book stores
in the mall and the structure of them
like what is this
interior you know what is the slug line
why are they written this way and like
to figure out
you know i'd written short stories or
whatever but to figure out like how do
you write this what does this look
like physically what does this look like
and so i remember transcribing
like i had a videotape of a um
an episode of homicide life on the
street you remember that television show
which i loved and i just took one of the
shows
you know now i could just google it and
probably find the pdf of the
the teleplay somewhere but i just took
that show this episode that i love so
much and i transcribed the whole thing
which meant i was stopping and
rewinding that you know to get all the
dialogue
and just sort of okay what does this
look like when you actually
write it like okay so this and you can
see
or i could see okay so lines of dialogue
which is you know
kind of something that we teach now but
i needed to see it because i didn't take
any taking any screenwriting classes or
anything
um at that point oh lines of dialogue
there's no
like block speeches like this like the
lines of dialogue are four or five words
sometimes less uh often less um
and they'll speak this much and then we
go into a new scene it was
um it was just useful to me to try to
figure out i mean
long after that i'm still trying to
figure out how to write a script
but like j like physically i needed to
physically see it
there was something about physically
seeing it and how it
looked on a page because um it's not
something that i grew up
looking at or reading right when you
read a
a story when you read a novel when you
read a short story it doesn't look like
a screenplay
i need to figure out what they look like
um
and but then just i watch
movies i watch movies because they ranch
the way the way that
um a movie can get you inside of a story
and get you inside of a perspective
um that was what was interesting to me
yeah figuring out how to tell them yeah
absolutely like
i'm i'm always interested in that now
um and as i've you know started going
when i went to film school and all that
sort of stuff
um but i don't ever remember thinking
like
this is gonna teach me how to tell a
story maybe i did
i don't know but i don't remember it if
i did
did you have plans to study film i mean
growing up you grew up in like central
california i grew up in central
california
um it was a discovery i made as a
teenager um
that um oh i'm interested in this
like from not having a social life and
just watching lots of movies
and i grew up in a um a pretty religious
household and we actually didn't have a
vcr and you know i'm a child of the
eighties i think you said junior
generation x i'm generic gen x just like
you
and um so watching videos on
at home on your vcr was a big way of
consuming movies for our generation and
i didn't have that available to me
but what we would do is
my mother if we had like uh you know she
has three sons
none of whom want to get up earlier than
11 a.m
on the weekend but she would give us
like you know if we do
this big chore like wash all the windows
around the house
we could then go to the video store and
we could rent a bunch of movies
and also we'd rent a vcr because we
didn't have one
and so this would be an opportunity for
me and my brothers to just
rent a bunch of stuff that we had wanted
to see but hadn't had the opportunity
um and so that really sort of sparked
something because the
they became um it's not just the
the movies themselves but the this
pleasure this thing that
was not available to me but then we
would have this these kind of
days of ecstasy where we got to see a
bunch of stuff
so i'll never forget like die hard when
i rented die hard
i watched that thing in the course of a
24 hour period i must have watched it
four times
um you know i was watching it two weeks
because i was the young i'm the youngest
and so i went last you know my brothers
got their picks
and they watched their film so i'm
staying up till one or two in the
morning
to watch die hard and then i think i
woke up early the next day at 8 00 a.m
or whatever to watch it again
um and i still love that movie to this
day it's a masterpiece
um so that sparked something
that kind of experience and then just
yeah
just being an awkward teenager and not
having much of a social life most of my
friday nights were spent
after we did finally get a vcr uh most
of my friday and saturday nights were
spent
renting stuff you know um yeah i grew up
in a small town so like um
the movies that i started to get
interested in as a teenager they didn't
come to our
um theaters so if i was gonna see
you know reservoir dogs or something
like that it was gonna be on video it
was not going to be
at the local theater although i yeah
that was
like as i'm sort of growing into um
going into this as a main focal interest
and trying to get my friends interested
and they were not i mean they like going
to the movies but
they didn't want to necessarily make
movies and they definitely didn't want
to see these like
um already the stuff that i would
already films that i was into
so i'll never forget like they forced me
to go see
um independence day which i did not want
to see and i hated
and then i forced them to go see living
leaving las vegas which they all had oh
wow
so yeah that so leaving las vegas did
come
which is surprising now that i think
about it um but it was probably
not oscar nominated that's probably why
our academy award nominated
um that's probably why it came but um
so yeah it's it's that it's it's the
that thing that was unavailable to me
that sparked something and then
then i just became really interested in
it and and as a way i would say if i'm
gonna
sort of be my own therapist as a way
of um cementing
a kind of um iconoclasm this this desire
to be different
from my peers oh they like independence
day
i'm not gonna be like them i'm gonna
like sex lies and videotape that's going
to be my kind
of film you know i got more and more
drawn to
art cinema independent cinema and from
that to european cinema
asian cinema that sort of stuff
why do you teach here at long beach city
college full-time job
opened up and i got lucky um
we you know i i for six years i was an
adjunct faculty member
at a bunch of different colleges and we
my wife and i lived up in west l.a and
we'd been in the same one bedroom
apartment for like eight years and we'd
saved up enough money to where we could
start looking to buy
and for what we could afford in culver
city which is a
like a two-bedroom condo and uh not the
best part of culver city
we could buy a a three-bedroom house
with a backyard in long beach in a good
neighborhood
and so um
we bought the house in 2010 and i was
still doing the adjunct teaching and
then a job opened up here
in 2011 and i got lucky and i got it
i mean it's no there's no like i just i
you know these jobs are not
um there there's not that many of them
um and so to get one that was
three miles from my house um no commute
tenure tracked i'm tenured now i just
got back from sabbatical
wow congratulations yeah it's um
it's it's a it's a good thing it's a
really good thing it makes my life as a
filmmaker
that much more feasible because i have
i have a real job and a regular job and
steady income and health benefits and
all that sort of stuff and
so it gives me an opportunity to go out
and make stuff and not have to worry
that
that it's going to kill me financially
because i
have a job i have a good job um and
you know i i went to community college
that's the first thing i did before i
i transferred up to san francisco state
and so
um i kind of understand this world
um pretty well the um
neither one of my parents went to
college my father has his um ged
and so i kind of understand coming into
this
um where you might come from a family
that's
you know like you're maybe gonna be the
first person from your family to
graduate from college and that sort of
stuff
not being able to afford to pay for four
years
at a uh you need to do the first two
years at community college because it's
just too expensive to do four years at a
ucla or wherever cal state long beach
um so i kind of understand the
circumstances that the students are
coming in
um from because my own experience um
and and it feels really good to also
make
the filmmaking world feel possible for a
group of students who
probably feel like it's not possible
this is not these are not kids that are
going to sc
you're in nyu or those kinds of places
and that
even though you know la's 20 miles away
it feels like another world um when
you're coming from a working class
background
um and your family and your dad's not an
agent
or a lawyer uh yeah and he doesn't feel
like you're connected to it and so it
feels um you know it feels like you know
i'm doing something useful in the world
to make it feel
um feasible for them possible
um that they could get into this field
get into this industry doesn't
necessarily mean that they're going to
get to be
christopher nolan or whoever because
there's
lots of people who want to be
christopher nolan or wes anderson or
pick whoever you want to pick
um but finding
um finding a job finding something that
they like to do
within the film and television industry
is absolutely possible
for them and it feels good to be able to
sort of
tell them that with authority and mean
it because it is true
they can so that that feels better
for me than um being someplace
else with a bunch of kids who you know
they're going to be fine they're going
to be fine no matter what
um if you can afford that tuition you're
going to be fine
and the connections yeah that when they
get out
yeah but even even if they don't do
anything in the like
you know there's all kinds of this has
got nothing to do with filmmaking but
there's all kinds of evidence that just
having a degree in the value of it it's
worth like 500 000
over the course of a career compared to
a high school diploma
um just having a degree and like but
those kids that come out of one of those
schools and they come out yeah they have
connections they probably have
a certain degree of wealth not all of
them
they're going to be fine they're going
to be fine yes they may
again they may not get to be the next
whoever but they're going to live a nice
upper middle class life
live in a nice house live in a safe
environment all that sort of stuff
and trying to help these kids see that
that's possible feels more
useful to me um so yeah
that's why i'm here do you see a
different eagerness
in some of the community college
students versus if you've ever
taught at a private school yeah i've
talked about a couple private schools a
couple
private four-year schools which who both
of which had really really good students
i don't want to
see i don't i don't okay that's okay
that's a bad question then no no i don't
want to
my last response i don't want to make it
because i had some really good students
at those schools
yeah really smart students um i can i
can ask another question no no it's not
that i'm trying to
what i don't it's not that the community
college students have
more eagerness what i actually see is
the opposite as i can see the way the
world weighs on them and how they feel
like this is never going to happen for
me
i can see how that's that just becomes
but this all
feels so um
out of reach and that is
um that's heartbreaking
you know to see that it's complete
opposite of what you see in a lot of
those other schools where those kids
don't necessarily feel like that
yeah um and so that's again that's part
of the gig that's part of this job is
like no
and and also it's like we've um
sometimes when you're young and you you
define
this notion of like who i'm gonna be if
i'm not
quentin tarantino or you know
christopher nolan or any of those kinds
of people
then i haven't made it no
that's not true um and
like helping them to understand that
they can
make stuff um
they have the capability like teaching
them how to make stuff first of all
teaching them how to
get the camera up on the sticks and how
to light a shot and all that sort of
stuff
helping them understand just those tools
um
and then just giving them the the um
helping them to find the agency like i
can do this
i can make something if i want to
um that's i think really really crucial
so that um who the hell knows what's
going to happen in 10 or 15 years
with your life like no one knows but the
feeling
that um if i get an idea if i feel
compelled by something if i feel
something strongly enough that i think
is a film
that they can then and they know how to
use the tools they can grab the tools
and try to go out and make it
they don't need anybody else's
permission i think that's a really
really important thing
to to help them feel that to help them
feel that agency
um making it uh
making it in this industry i don't i
don't know what that
i i as i get older i have no idea what
that means anymore
so yeah i don't know i don't know if
that answers the question yeah it does
it actually sparks
several other questions um firstly
what are the stories that a lot of your
students want to tell here at
long beach city college i mean they vary
documentary
well yeah it's a lot it's mostly
narrative there are some documentary
the documentaries can be the strongest
stuff not always
stuff that happens in their life stuff
that they that they find interesting
stuff that's typical of college students
and then i'll have students that are
telling completely sort of out of the
blue stories like i have a student who
made a
a film that is very much influenced by
um third cinema do you know what third
cinema is
third cinema was a term that was um
sort of created out of a manifesto by a
couple of filmmakers from argentina
and brazil like dogma but for
for yeah but south america yeah but this
is in the late 60s
and it's it's um highly political
filmmaking
very much interested in a kind of
anti-colonial
anti-imperial anti-imperialist ideology
and it's just really interesting to me
that i had a student
that even knew what third cinema is it's
not something that we're teaching
um you know in our in our introductory
courses so he knew what third cinema was
and so
he wanted to make something that was
um sort of referenced that style as well
as
bertolt brecht and jean-luc godard so
the point i'm making is i get because it
is such a diverse
student body i get a wide
sort of bandwidth here of different
possibilities of what the students can
be making
so that's really interesting they do
come in but they come in also with less
resources we have less resources as a
school
than you know some of the bigger film
schools and the students have less
resources they cannot come in
and go well i've got 25 000 to make my
student film
you know which some students at some of
the other schools do
um but as i constantly tell them
limitations are
absolutely part of filmmaking and
something that we have to sort of
get used to and start to use like you
got to use your limitations
do you think that helps with their
storytelling it can
i mean i i almost think that this is
like um
you're building you're building the
proper muscles
for making this sort of stuff um the
example i used
for them is someone like the coen
brothers who you know are making these
films in this range from
15 million dollars to 35 million dollars
and they are
also talk about how they don't have
enough money in enough time
right which to my students having 15 to
35 million dollars seems like you would
have plenty of money and plenty of time
but it is the nature of the thing just
the nature of
filmmaking that there's never enough of
either one of those things
and so it becomes a muscle that you need
to exercise
um or that you need to build in an
exercise um
because you've got to figure out okay i
thought we were
going to have a full day to get this
scene
we only have an hour so how are we going
to do it because that's going to happen
over and over and over again i don't
care what level you're working at
that happens all the time and so that
becomes a muscle that you have to
develop
like figuring out a way what is the
scene about how are we planning on
shooting it
how can we simplify that and still have
the thing be
what it's supposed to be um so that
it makes them better filmmakers just
being able to sort of
deal with that situation because it
happens all the time
um the most i call tell them constantly
the most important
commodity that they have is time and
there's never enough of it
so you try um you try to get as much out
of your shoot days you try to make your
shoot days as long as you possibly can
and get as much shot on your shoot days
as you can
because you're not getting that time
back um
so it can make their storytelling
stronger and just it makes
their filmmaking better
and do most of the students come in with
the idea even if they don't totally know
what they want to be
that they want to be on a level of a
tarantino or some kind of an auteur
rather than they want to be working in
the industry making
incredible money like they want to sort
of put their name on something or they
don't mind being part of a huge project
making a living
it's both it's both and i i like
something like the class where they get
to make their
their own short film that is does a lot
for self-discovery
um it usually
one or two one they're going to go one
or two ways they're going to do that
and and it's going to be um so exciting
even though it's so stressful
that that it sort of cements for them
okay this is what i want to do i want to
have my name on things and
for the other half of them they'll go oh
my god why would anyone want to do this
why would you want to go through all
this stress right you know trying to
find a
diner you know nobody will let us shoot
in the diner or if they do
they all want to be there and so our
dialogue is not going to work or
whatever
um that they'll go i you know i want to
do this but
i do not want to try to put together my
own projects let somebody put it
together and i'll come in and
run the camera or whatever
yeah so it's about half and half
regarding documentaries
is observational documentary filmmaking
your favorite kind
or yeah it probably is um
i don't know there's something about
that fly on the wall thing so this is
i'm going to contradict what i said
earlier about the sort of
um subjective style of some of those
other filmmakers there's something about
um whether it's the the voyeurism of it
the feeling of um being able to just see
inside someone else's life
um unimpeded um
that i don't know it's so exciting it's
so
um i can get awestruck like
um a movie like salesman have you ever
seen salesman the measles
documentary about the bible salesman oh
you should watch that film
if you're interested in documenting
filmmaking you should watch them
um or even like yeah frederick
weissman's um high school
um but in salesmen just watching
you just watch you watch these bible
salesmen and you watch them
fail and watch them struggle
and there's no judgment there's no
commentary there's no interruption it's
just
watching them watching these men
struggle in what now seems like a kind
of antiquated
um job although we have telemarketing
now which is the same thing
essentially um
and i don't know you get so much
information from that you learn so much
without them having to sort of
um hit you over the head um with what
they're trying to get you to understand
you know i mean it's it's it's no
different than death of a salesman i
mean
you're getting a kind of a very similar
message with glenn gary glenn ross
you're getting a very kind of similar
message but
like um there's no didacticism in it you
just
watch you watch and you watch there's a
great moment in it where
the guy is the main character paul he's
just gone up to somebody's
house and he wasn't able to make a sale
and
they follow him back to his car and they
just sit
in this car with him and he's just kind
of muttering to himself i think he
starts singing a little bit
and we're just watching and do that and
he's just kind of dejected
you know he's got a good now he's got to
start the car he's got to go to the next
house and try to sell the bible to them
um and it's not orchestrated
it's not created um they're just
following this guy around with their
camera and their and their inaugural
sound recorder
and um i don't know it feels so real and
also
authentic but it also just feels so
human um they really respond to that
sort of stuff
i think when you had a q a for your film
uh
jonas you had another teacher in the
audience and he talked about being
like in anthropology and sometimes going
up to
subjects for lack of a better word
without any film in the camera
and getting them totally desensitized do
you think that's possible
yeah it's possible it may not be ethical
but it's possible i mean there is a
whole school like someone like bill
nichols again
talks about um ethnography and it's um
you know one of the things that happens
when you're making a documentary you're
going into a place
you are just taking something from
someone you're just using their lives
to create something that you think is
interesting and
that you're going to use for who knows
what um
and so there is a kind of um ethical
dilemma
there or an ethical question i guess you
should say
um and i mean lots of people have
written about this there's been all
kinds of stuff about um the
the ethics of doing that of going
especially going into
a different culture maybe a poor country
and trying to document that poverty
but there's nothing that the film is
going to do that's going to solve those
people's issues you're just kind of
using their poverty to promote yourself
ultimately as a filmmaker
um so i mean that i think but that's
kind of
been a thing that people have gotten
more aware of um
now and so people tend to acknowledge
their own presence and perhaps how
problematic some of that is
um but yeah i mean getting
i will say like it's one of the other
things we talk about when we talk about
documentary film um
[Music]
getting people to not be aware
of the camera is very very difficult
it's you know it's the least
natural thing in the world to have a
camera like pointed at you
um is one of the things not even about
documentary but trying to explain
students how difficult
um the job of an actor is you know you
got lights
you got a camera you got a guy holding
the sound
uh the boom mic you got all these people
watching you
and somebody says be natural this is the
least
natural experience of my life how can i
be natural
and so it's the same thing if you're
making a documentary everybody becomes
hyper aware of the camera
um you know some a friend of mine used
to say you could throw a grenade
into a room and you'll get a more
natural response than if you bring a
camera into it
um and so one of the things that that i
think lots of filmmakers do is you
so you don't try to hide from that you
don't try to hide from the fact that
people are aware of the camera and
they're going to interact with it
um you know you let that be part of the
the movie um something like um american
movie
have you ever seen an american movie
that chris smith and sarah price you
know
mark borchardt he's just he's directly
addressing that camera he's performing
for the camera a lot and
they just let that stuff play you know
they're not trying to be purely
observational at all
um and i mean it's a movie about a guy
making a movie so it'd be kind of hard
to ignore the
the technology of of a movie
do you ever plan to make another
documentary again
so i know you did one on your family
most particularly on your brother
yeah um i don't think so i don't have
any plans to
i'm much more of a narrative filmmaker
than a documentary filmmaker
um if something were to interest i mean
it's like i said when we're talking
about students like if something sparks
your interest and they want to pick up a
camera and make it then i would
um but i don't have any designs like
everything
that i have planned the thing that i'm
finishing now the stuff that i have
planned for the future
they're all narrative um i'm just i
don't know
doc i think documentary
um documentaries
it's extremely difficult and can feel
like it's
never i mean they all feel like they're
never ending but there's something
documentary you know it's just it can be
you know whatever hoop dreams was i
think they did that that was eight years
you know um from the time they first
started shooting those kids until the
time that the film actually premiered
that may not be right but i believe it's
eight years um
it's just so time consuming but
who knows but i don't have any plans to
what advice would you have for
one of your students or someone
listening who wants to make a film about
their family their environment where
they grew up something that's very close
to them and the pros and cons with that
and how the people in the film
eventually see themselves whether they
like it or not
and i realize i'm throwing a lot of
questions out there
yeah the whole whole gamut of i mean
my advice is always if you're interested
in making something make it
um it can i mean my family was very
supportive of me
doing that film it didn't it didn't
bring any
sort of big issues out no big fights
um i mean you certainly don't want to
just show up with a camera and say okay
i'm making a film about
our family it's certainly something that
you're gonna have to talk through
with people um
i i just i
relationships and all that sort of stuff
i mean that that's i think on a
case-to-case basis i would just say
generally speaking
it goes back to the thing that we talked
about before
what's your point of view why are you
telling the story what's interesting
about this story
there are any number of movies the
filmmakers making
films about their family so
what is your point of entry um what is
the audience's point of entry
um i think that's the most important
thing to talk about
um you know i mean you gotta yeah if
they're
i know of multiple people who have
started making
documentaries oriented around their
family and then
stuff is sort of blown up within the
relationships and that was the end of
the movie
and the movie didn't get finished so you
got to be careful that
but i didn't go through that experience
so i don't know what the i'm sure there
are warning signs
um for that thing sort of happening i'm
thinking specifically of a filmmaker i
know she was making a film about her
sister i don't even remember what the
topic was
but she was around her sister and her
husband and as she's you know shooting
stuff she recognizes
oh their marriage is falling apart and
that was kind of the end of the movie
after that um so you know i mean
but that's a that's a case by case you
got to recognize that stuff as you're
going in
um but i i i always go back to like
why are you telling the story what's
what's your point of view why is it
unique
what's different about it um
because they're i mean as cameras get
easier and easier to get a hold of they
get cheaper um
we can shoot on our phone everybody's
making a movie
why does anybody need to see yours um
what's your point of view
now here's the other side of that though
i would say this doesn't matter
um even if you're a movie to some degree
or another it doesn't matter if you
really feel compelled to make it you
should make it
even if it's the same as 10 other movies
you should make it or 100 other movies
because the um regret of not making it
is
way worse than the feeling of oh
they made that movie's my movie's just
like their movie
that doesn't feel great but i should
have made that feels
way worse way worse um
but if you want your movie to stand out
you got to figure out your perspective
and point of view you may have touched
on this earlier but i was
hoping we could just go over again the
modes of documentary film
okay so well these are not my modes
these are bill nichols modes uh
so there is expository um
the observational mode which is sort of
completely quote unquote objective where
you stand back and you don't interfere
there's a participatory mode which is
the mode where the filmmakers interact
so someone like michael moore
would be making sort of participatory
documentaries
there's self-reflexive mode which is um
films that are essentially about their
own making
so there's a very famous um soviet film
from like 1920 called the man
with the movie camera it's like 1920
something like that in the man with a
movie camera you watch
the cameraman shoot the film that you're
watching you watch the editor edit the
film that you're watching you watch an
audience watch the film that you're
watching
it's a film that's um sort of only
um the only truth it can offer is that
well it knows it's a movie so here's
this is the truth that i'm giving you
um it's very self-reflexive uh
there's poetic there's a poetic mode so
that's like the
godfrey reggio films uh koianna scotsie
those films um they're very lyrical
am i forgetting something i feel like
i'm forgetting something five
observational participatory
self-reflexive
uh poetic then there's
um the performative which is the grizzly
man
and um thin blue lines sort of
um and something like stories we tell
and then expository
so six i think that's right
so then cinema verite cinema verite
would be like participatory
story yeah because some of it there's a
difference
i'm gonna get very pedantic but there's
a difference between cinema verite
and direct cinema direct cinema is
purely observational it's frederick
weissman it's
no interaction whatsoever and cinema
verite there's lots of handheld camera
and they're out on the street but there
will be interaction there will be
something like american movie or the
films or roger and me the
michael moore film so you brought up
werner herzog and errol morris and so
i'm thinking like the thin blue line or
into the abyss
where you have multiple points of view
and i think
i got this from something you said truth
doesn't exist it's only perception
which is excellent yeah i like that make
a t-shirt out of it yeah
especially in this day and age twitter
and all that so
talk about uh documentary filmmaking and
perception so really is it just
perception we're going after
because since truth is so there's so
many truths
everyone's reality is different yeah i
mean i don't i don't know if
we're going after anything i mean i i i
think that
filmmakers who are more attuned to that
idea
um will probably make
more interesting work um
oh boy i don't i'm an opinionated guy so
i'm trying not to
um i i like there's just
i'm trying to say something about this
filmmaker is not very good but this
filmmaker
is um i i there's
there's there's just there's something
about
understanding that um
trying to present something as an
absolute
um perhaps yeah maybe it's this day and
age or
but perhaps is not the best way to sort
of get at any kind of truth
if you're trying to present sort of an
absolute thing
um because it's maybe an argument it's
not even an argument
um i don't know maybe we're just beyond
that
as a culture i don't know if we need it
um there's an argument to be made that
we absolutely need it
when when you have um someone
in the most powerful position in the
world who just
is gaslighting constantly and everyone
around him is gaslighting constantly
and so we need some sort of standard of
truth right
um but within a if we're thinking about
in terms of a film
i don't know it sometimes it feels like
it's it's lacking
um because it's so absolute i'm trying
to think of an example
where i where it shows how problematic
it is and right now and but i don't want
to
right well if you think about let's say
into the abyss herzog is showing
multiple points of view
of what happened that night you know or
thin blue line same thing what happened
that night
everybody had their own thing even west
of memphis
you know different different things and
so to me that's terribly interesting
because everybody
was showing a different version of their
own reality yeah
what's interesting i guess about it too
is that so especially someone like aaron
morris
is he is but i he's figured out he's
you know the whole point of the same
blue line um
is he's figured out the truth right he's
letting us know that like okay we're
getting these different
perspectives and i'm going to show you
sort of
these reenactments where we get those
different perspectives sort of played
out
but then he leaves us with that audio
tape of
whatever the guy's name essentially
confessing to the crime right
um and so there's a kind of ultimate
authority that he's taken up
with that where like i found the truth
like i was showing you all
these variations of the truth but here's
what really happened and this guy just
admitted to it
um so there's a kind of authority or
power that he's taking as the ultimate
truth-teller which is
kind of interesting um and part of it
coming from i think his background as a
as a private investigator he's you know
they think of that movie as an
investigation
the way he's reenacting he's doing his
reenactment so he can see if that sort
of
holds truth in his investigation
um yeah i don't know i mean when i
think about stories we tell and and
she's
she's not coming to any conclusions
she's trying to figure out what this
family history is
and um but she's not you know there's a
whole challenge that happens have you
seen that film
i haven't it sounds good there's a whole
challenge that happens
with her and somebody else involved in
her with her family and
where he questions why she has the right
to tell this story or this part of the
story he has the
he should be telling that part of the
story it's a really fascinating thing
because kind of like what we were just
talking about earlier when i was talking
about bias
there is something about when you pick
up the camera and say i have the right
to do this there might be a whole
bunch of other people who stand up and
say no you don't
you don't have the right to do this um
so i don't know hey i don't if it's
what somebody should or should not do i
guess
i'm sure i can think of a you know march
of the penguins that's a fun film that's
completely expository you know
there's nothing wrong with that
necessarily um
so they're it's not that there's no
value in that sort of stuff i just
always find the other films more
interesting
i guess do you ever recommend people
storyboard
for documentary film if they're going to
do
um like reenactments i would um
you know just because to design those
you got to design those just like you
would a narrative film
um i mean if if what they're going to do
like if they're considering
um a really sort of
um complex sequence uh
the the editing sequence that they're
considering then i would storyboard it
like okay how is trying to figure out
how this is going to cut together
right um the reason you storyboard like
does this stuff fit um so if they were
planning on doing something where they
weren't sure
then yes i would but
it's not something that i make my
students do who are making documentaries
because they have so much to do in terms
of preparation getting questions ready
all that sort of stuff getting all their
permission
and they're gonna spend so much more
time trying to cut theirs together
um you know they they don't have
the um the luxury of having a script and
then a storyboard and because they don't
know what they're going to get
necessarily
um you know it might be i know i know of
documentary filmmakers who do it after
they've shot right they've shot all they
got all their footage
and they're trying to sort of as they're
putting together some sort of
audiovisual script and then they might
storyboard a sequence
to look at it to see this is going to
cut this to this to this that kind of
idea
so just depend what they're doing that
was actually was going to ask you next
is then
once they have an audio track and then
working off that is sort of their script
and then piecing together the visuals
from there i mean is that how yeah
you know one of the best things this is
not mine this is a friend of mine mary
trunk
uh who's a documentary filmmaker she's
great
she made this film a family documentary
called the watershed
um 10 or 15 years ago whenever it was
um and she talked about how she edited
it um like it was a radio show
um and so she would not even she would
completely ignore what was happening in
the visuals and just sort of piece it
together
based upon what she was listening to the
sequence that made sense to her
orally and then go back and sort of
stitch together the video keeping that
construction of the audio first i mean
you know i know documentary editors who
will not work and
rightfully so will not work until you
have that script
written because it's just too um
it's just too much material you can't
put it together without it
you know once you have that thing
stitched together then you can make
choices about rearranging and all that
sort of stuff
do you think filmmakers want their
viewers to feel they're in a moral
position
like a higher viewing ground when
they're watching their documentary or no
that's just
something i'm predicting some of them
some of them might
um i mean it depends upon the film you
know
i'm i'm more interested in films that
don't judge
their characters or their subjects um
but some of them might want you to be in
this
sort of um
taking a kind of moral authority i mean
it just depends upon the movie i don't
know it depends upon the subject matter
what they're doing
i'm sure i mean there are multiple
examples i mean speaking of
sort of moral authorities from someone
like michael moore takes a kind of moral
authority
um in most of his movies um and
wants his audience to align with him in
that authority
um but i don't know
it depends upon what they're doing all
right if we look at gray gardens
i don't think that was really put out
there it was more just no the measles
yeah the i mean
the measles are that's i mean one of the
same guys we made salesmen
um i think that's one of the reasons
that they're so celebrated
is that their ability to get into these
very
intimate personal
places and experiences and we get to see
these things that maybe we shouldn't be
able to see but we get to see these
things
and we see them without judgment we see
them without the
you know those
they don't condescend they don't
condescend to the bible salesman they're
working in florida they don't condescend
to those
women in great gardens um they are
trying to give us some kind of portrait
of humanity that's what makes them so
good
um so interesting um
so but i i also don't i don't
for me to take an authority to say what
filmmaker should or shouldn't do i don't
think it's right either you know i think
you can make a film an interesting film
any number of ways and so there might be
a way for someone
um there are ways for people to do that
you know i like roger and me and michael
moore
film and he's he's standing above his
subjects for the most part you know
um so yeah there's lots of interesting
there's lots of ways to do interesting
stuff
i jokingly said that i'm bringing up old
examples of films
do you think documentary filmmaking has
changed especially with reality tv and
especially with the culture of being
so sped up yeah i mean
in the way that in that way all in
narrative filmmaking and documentary
filmmaking have changed they're both
much
faster than they once were and i mean
also in the same way they're much more
feasible for anybody
right anybody can you can shoot stuff
very cheaply
right and that makes a lot of sense um
it helps a lot when you're making a
documentary film now
when you're rolling that camera you
don't have to worry about all the film
that's burning through
right with each one of those um each
minute cost you
so many hundred dollars of film stock
and
and um um
development um now you don't have to
worry about it just pop the card in
and just keep going um so it's changed
that way and that allows you to shoot
more
so maybe it's harder to edit and all
that sort of stuff
um has it gotten fat i mean the
culture's gotten faster
like the culture is just faster um
and so in the way we consume things is
faster and
um you know like the idea
that the measles had no idea when they
made salesmen in 1960 that somebody
could watch it on their
phone right that was not even they had
just gotten these cameras now that they
could take out of the studio and start
following people around and these
these kind of handheld devices that
wasn't feasible 10 years before
so yeah of course it's changed and of
course the documentary has changed
because of that
is it better or worse i don't know i
don't like to make those moral judgments
like
i was talking about this was somebody
else oh when i was doing color
i don't hear the other day we were
talking and
you know like my students now
they're used to um
they shoot stuff they
edit it and they put it up on youtube
and it all happens in like a day you
know they grab
their phone they go out and shoot
something they don't really plan it out
they just see what they're doing
and so one of the things that i'm doing
is sort of training them
i'm trying to break down that process so
now that they're planning
more like that their idea they fully
form an idea
you know they write a script in other
words and they plan it out in
pre-production
they take their time with it they shoot
over multiple days
you know full days of shooting all that
sort of stuff
but there's nothing wrong with the way
they were doing it for their
youtube you know videos right there's
that process like that's a really
important part of
their um learning they're learning how
to shoot stuff they're learning how to
edit stuff they're learning how what
they're interested in
and it's really fast and it's consumed
really fast
and it's forgotten about you know just
as fast
um but i you know i like it
i don't want to pass judgment on that
whether that's good or bad because i
don't know i don't think
i don't think it's either um but it's
just the way it is
right and they're they're used to it and
so um
i don't know it's like documentary for a
while there in the early early aughts
it was the thing that it was um there
was this kind of box off explosion box
office explosion with like fahrenheit
a few other movies march of the penguins
um searching for sugar man yeah thank
you for sure
that's right yeah that's great um
but now man it's hard and it's hard
for them to exist in the box office
space um
so i don't know what that means for
their style
um you know
trying to think what's the last doc
that i saw that wasn't like a true crime
thing that was on
um you know netflix or whatever i'm
trying to think of the last feature film
doc that i
saw in the last two three years
i know there's been some stuff but i
can't even think about it
um well hbo did
um the inventor about uh
the theranose founder oh yeah i didn't
see that so good i didn't see that
um nor if i wasn't there somebody wrote
a book about it right
two didn't they maybe that i don't know
but it's
elizabeth elizabeth holmes right yeah
yeah
so i mean it seems like some of that is
coming back more into the mainstream
into the art house cinema
but you're right in terms of just the
the main you know
i won't mention the name of the theaters
but yeah these mainstream theaters that
don't show sort of art house cinema i
don't see a lot
yeah well it's just man it's just so i
mean documentary
anything it's so hard to get people to
see your movie
it is so hard because there is so much
stuff you know
um i i went to see the souvenir
yesterday which i loved it's such a good
movie it's so well crafted and well made
well act the acting is unbelievable and
then i stupidly looked up like box
office stuff
which i never do but i was just curious
because here's this movie she's a
british filmmaker
tilda swinton's in it but she's not the
lead it's her daughter who's the lead
who's not
known at all and the the guy who's
playing her boyfriend
he's a great actor but he's not known in
the states you know
and here 824 has yeah and they've spent
a decent chunk of money promoting the
movie
and so he's like okay well let me see i
wonder if they're doing
i mean it's not doing well at all it's
less than a million dollars in box
office and i imagine
they've spent you know and that's that's
at least
a three million dollar movie it might be
a five to seven million dollar movie
and they've spent that much or more on
on marketing um i'd have to think and
how they're going to make that money
back so it just and this is not a
criticism i'm glad that they put that
movie out i want that movie to be in the
world i want to have it find its
audience and all that sort of stuff
but you go oh my god they're going to
lose money on this movie and that
that's bad for the cult that's bad for
the
film world it's bad for because 8 24 is
putting out interesting stuff
and so i want them to do well and so
when they and especially with that kind
of movie and
uh sorry if i'm this is going to ruin so
i want them to do well
um so i mean it's not just documentary
film it's narrative film it's
um as i saw some
the depressive thing depressing thing
about um
paul schrader's last film first reform
you know i mean that's a movie that was
made for
i think around three million dollars an
a24 bought it
for 500 000 um
so there's all this um there's all this
that creates downward pressure when
you're trying to make a movie
you know we we have a budget for three
million dollars
well paul schrader's movie oscar
nominated movie
with the master of the american cinema
it's a great lead actor
who's known cost three million dollars
and they only sold it for five hundred
thousand dollars so you need to make
your movie for five hundred thousand
dollars
and if it doesn't have and you're not
paul schrader and you don't have ethan
hawk you have a
you have a known actor but a lesser
known actor so actually you need to make
it for 250 000
and so there's all this downward
pressure on the people producing movies
because the
um the audiences now i imagine they've
made their money back at this point
got once they got the oscar nominations
and all that sort of stuff i'm just
i'm sure they've made the the rest of
the budget back
um but that's a it's a really really
difficult time
um to try to make try to make anything
that's not 30 million or more or less
than a hundred thousand dollars
um anything from 100 000 to 29 million
is really really hard to get made um
because
it's very hard for the people who are
going to fund it to see how they're
going to get their money back
and that's no different than in
documentary film but it is easier to
make a documentary film for less than a
hundred thousand dollars than it is a
narrative
i know you have a lot of students
that'll probably come in that maybe they
have no idea what they want to do
and that's totally natural you can be in
your 40s and 50s and not know what you
want to do
but how does that translate into the
films that they make if they're sort of
this ambiguous question of
what are they going to do with the rest
of their lives where do they fit into
this
you know working world whatever how does
that translate into the films that they
make
here the films that they make here um
well that probably means that they don't
know how to
like if they're not sure um
then they'll probably go into the film
not sure and so there won't be anything
specific about it i mean i would say
one of the things that um that
students um struggle with the most not
just in their filmmaking but kind of
everything and what they write
their analytical papers is everything
feels very generic
it feels very broad it feels very
borrowed and so the thing that they but
that comes with youth um but the thing
that
they have to sort of work on and getting
used to is getting specific
getting specific in terms of their ideas
like what do you want this to really be
about
getting specific if we're talking about
in terms of
a film a narrative film getting specific
about what your character does what do
they do what are they doing in a scene
um what is the scene about how specific
can you get
um so i i would say that that sort of
[Music]
directionlessness i don't like calling
it that because that that feels a little
judgmental but
just a sense of not knowing if they're
not sure
they will be unsure in making
you know um
[Music]
once somebody figures out that that's
what they're interested in that's what
they want to do they will get
more confident and more sure about what
they're trying to express
too and they will get more specific in
their the content
i always think it's such a gift to know
what you want to do when you're like
16 17 yeah yeah it is
i was i mean i did but i don't think i
was 70. i was probably i was probably
18.
hey you know i've been like um
but i also didn't know anything about it
like i didn't grow up with a camera in
my hand
i was not a photographer and i was like
i said before like
there's no film culture i didn't have i
don't know anything about filmmaking
it's actually a story i tell my students
that are feeling intimidated or feel
like they don't belong or whatever
because that was me when i was at um
san francisco state i always tell that
story like they the first production
class that they used to make you take
because there's so many students they
can't put you all in production right
away but they call it a production class
and it was a large lecture class of i
don't know 100 students 125 students
whatever and you never touch a camera
in the production class you just get
lectured
too and the first day the instructor
says something like uh and a film
camera standard speed is and it felt
like
the other 99 students all said 24 frames
a second
i didn't know i didn't know anything
about film production or
you know standard camera speed or
anything like that sync sound
so i there was this feeling of like oh
my god i am completely
um i'm out of my depth everybody else
here knows more than i do there's no way
i'm going to be able to catch up
i don't know anything about film
production i don't know anything about
cameras i don't know anything about this
technology
can i actually do this so it's a story i
tell my students because you know
i mean it's not like it came to me and
i'm still learning i'm still learning
about technology but it's a story i tell
my students just to know that like
you're absolutely not the only person
who's ever sat down
in a film class and not known all of
this stuff or understood it and you can
come in as a complete layman
um but that doesn't mean that you can't
be interested in film and ultimately
sort of become a filmmaker that is just
that's just learning that's just picking
up the gear and learning the gear
um that takes time but it's not like
some impossible mountain that you can't
climb
um so i think that's like that's like a
crucial thing
you know this is sort of answering a
question that we had in one of the other
segments
um especially for this population of
students um
because like again the equipment can
feel like it's from another world
because
if i tell them you know that that 5d
costs a couple thousand dollars
they don't have a couple thousand
dollars to throw down on a 5d
um or you know they get to use in our
more advanced classes they get to use a
canon c300 which is a ten thousand
dollar camera without any lenses on it's
a ten thousand dollar camera and so
that can be you know and it is the
difference between those students and
students at
uh like a four-year private university
okay
cool you know let me get my hands on it
great you know um
so um i don't know how i got them i'm
off on a tangent no no i like it
oh sorry so when you were at san
francisco state
did you then eventually feel like okay
i have my own way into this it doesn't
have to be like everybody else and i'm
okay with that
i mean yeah that you know san francisco
is just culturally it's just different
than
los angeles and i mean that's a very um
independence not even the right word
it's a very gorilla style
like there's not that that's the school
that's
that's geared more towards the
avant-garde and documentary there's some
narrative filmmakers i was a narrative
filmmaker
my mentor there she's in there and she's
still there she's a narrative filmmaker
um but um
i never felt like i was um ostracized or
outside i just felt like i
didn't know enough and when i got out of
there i still didn't feel like i knew
enough that's why i went to grad school
that was one of the main reasons i went
to grad school i mean i got to make
um a couple films one really this first
one doesn't really count
i got to make one film and and i you
know
i directed a film but i realized while
i'm doing i don't know
what i'm doing and you know and you
shouldn't so but that was and i don't
know enough about the equipment i don't
know
enough about the technology i
and i knew i actually wanted to teach i
knew that that was the way i was going
to try to um
make a living i mean i knew a few things
i knew i wanted to make my own
films the only thing i was interested is
in was making my own stuff
um and i knew that i wasn't going to
fall out of school
and be able to make a living doing that
so i
had to figure out a way to
to do that to try to make my own stuff
and still be able to pay the rent
and i'm too um egotistical to do it as
an assistant editor on like reality
television or something i just
there's just people who can do that are
just they're better people than me
because i just couldn't
i could not do it so i figured i was
going to teach so i need to learn more
so i can
you know claim to have the authority to
be able to teach a class
and i just need to learn where i need to
make more films so then i went to
grad school so when i got out of there i
felt better but i
still knew i needed to learn more and i
still need to learn more
like you continually learning
every time you do it every single time
eli how did you know that you were a
filmmaker and not a film watcher
that's a really good question so that
was kind of like the thing that i was
going through at san francisco state
maybe i don't know enough about this
technology maybe i should just maybe i
should go on and get a phd like that was
something that i would
seriously considering um
but for whatever i don't know how you
know
other than you keep having the
um the drive to
make something i think that's probably
the
the test like one of the things i tell
the students you know they
they kind of don't know what they're
getting themselves into the first time
they make even just a short film
and so when it's all over and they're
stressed out and they feel like their
movie's not as
good as it could have been or it's not
what they wanted to make because
it's a movie um and
i tell them that that's the test the
test is though
you went through all that stress it was
incredibly hectic
you're ultimately feel like
the film could be better which is what
everybody thinks after they make a movie
so you're not 100 happy with the
finished product
but the test is if you wake up in a
couple days or a couple weeks in a
couple months or a couple months and you
want to make something again
then you want to be a filmmaker you know
um and so the
the drive to like oh i
i'm interested in this i'm interested in
using the camera to try to
get at ideas or tell stories or
project some perspective of the world um
if that doesn't go away and it hasn't
gone away yet
um that's that's how i knew but i mean
it was
there was a question that was you know
in those moments like i was describing
where
oh my god they all know more than i do
and there's something about just
filmmaking um
because it's so heavily tilted towards
men or guys and
they are so full of canby not all guys
can be so full of bravado and trying to
prove themselves
um film sets are so full of guys trying
to prove how much they know what they've
done and
um so that can be really intimidating
like that oh i don't know as much as
these guys
are talking about a lens that i don't
know anything about
they're talking about something with a
camera they're talking about something
with a dolly shot that i don't know
anything about
um and so that can make you go
okay this is not i'll just be the guy
who
maybe i'll write reviews or whatever or
i'll
i'll write a do a dissertation on mike
lee films because i love mike lee or
whatever um
and um
but then the oh this is an idea i mean
i should write that down you know you
start writing something
the great thing about um you know if you
if you are
a um like me
i consider myself like a writer director
i write my own stuff and i
and i make it nobody can stop me
there's nothing stopping me from writing
a script there's nothing styled like
that doesn't cost
any money it's just my time and if i'm
um
i'm enjoying it and i feel like it's
interesting
and it can turn into something then i
can just do that
and then i can make the decision whether
or not i want to try to make it
you know um that
i don't know that's still that still
holds a lot of pleasure
for me if it stops if it's not it's not
pleasurable anymore
i'll stop doing it because filmmaking is
too hard filming is way too hard to do
something that's not
like you're not getting anything out of
it it doesn't feel
it's not fun it doesn't feel like um
you're doing anything interesting
you know you have a film about religion
that you wrote and direct but you say
it's not
faith-based yeah it's not a faith-based
film but it's a film about religion
yeah um i guess religion is a subject
matter
but um faith-based means to me
that um that it's a movie
it would be a movie that's trying to get
the audience to believe
in this specific um religious doctrine
because that's what most
face pa most faith-based films do
um and so it's not that it's it's it's
not a film that's not trying to
um proselytize at all um
you know i grew up i grew up in that
world i grew up an evangelical christian
and so naturally it's something that i
find interesting
um and i could um
tell a specific story about it i thought
so that's why i got interested or
decided to make it
and how has it been to or you had the
film hasn't been released yet right no
no yeah we're not finished yet okay not
finishing
almost almost i'm i'm in the midst of
color and
sound design and all that sort of stuff
but we're almost there
when you were creating the protagonist
for the film did you start with
a problem or a dilemma that needed to be
solved
yeah i guess i did i mean i i knew i
wanted to make a film in the world and i
knew i wanted to design it around a
scenario
where a character who is devout
um goes through a crisis a character
who's
only seen or understood the world
in one way is then put into a situation
where it kind of
blows up their world view i knew that
was it the circumstances of
how we got there or what place they were
put in
um i didn't know but i knew that's the
situation that i wanted i knew what the
character was like
and what kind of situation i wanted to
put them in or what kind of how i want
to change their context i guess
how long did it take you to write the
script i wrote the first script of the
first draft of the script
10 years ago wow so this idea
it's called faith right was that the
original title okay
had been probably swirling around you
all your life maybe
yeah i mean well yeah when you grow up
grow up that way i mean it's going to
inform your
um your outlook and certainly inform
what you think of as
could be interesting narrative material
and i had finished the
the documentary and done the festival
thing with it and
um but knew i was like i want to do
um i want to do narrative so i sat down
and i had a couple other scripts but
neither one of them were either good and
he could and i want to write something
new and so i sat down and wrote
something new
um and that's what came out and
then it was a process of okay that's the
first draft of the script
i wrote a couple more drafts of the
script over the next year or year and a
half
and um how am i going to try to make it
and so
what i did which i still recommend to
people is recommended students
what i did was i just started looking
for producers who worked in the
independent
art space you know they made like
already american movies
cheaply um not things that you know i
wasn't sending to people who were making
15 million dollar
movies i'm making i'm standing in the
people who are making movies for 2
million or less
and to see if it not just that but also
films that i
liked films that i responded to the idea
being if i'm going to
get the money to to make this i need to
make it cheaply enough because it would
be my first feature
and also i you you don't want to bark up
spend your time barking up the wrong
tree
right i'm not going to send it to people
who are making low-budget
thrillers or low-budget horror films
because it's just not like nothing wrong
with those kinds of films this is not my
avenue um and so i sent it to lots of
people mostly you get ignored
um that's kind of the nature of the
thing most time people just don't
respond
some nice not for us rejections
and then mike ryan is a producer out in
new york and i sent it to him
specifically because he had produced two
movies one called junebug
with amy adams that i just loved um well
two movies that i love junebug and then
another movie
kelly reichert's second movie old joy he
was a producer on both of those films
and i loved them and they were
in the same style that i wanted to make
this film in
and he responded to the material so um
but then off we went but from that
period it was still another
six years or so before we actually
started to make the movie
it just takes that long we wrote more
drafts got into some
this thing out in new york where we got
some money people to read it
and sony pictures classics
but it still took forever finally we
were able to do it
was that the whole 10-year journey or
was there times when you weren't sure
that this was a topic you want to
explore are you always
no i'm stubborn all hell so when i said
this is a movie i
said this is maybe you know i i like um
i don't know there's uh maybe this is
complete arrogance
um but uh i feel like i understand what
makes a movie
and so um that i would be interested in
i guess
then you know some other people may not
think it's a movie but for me i was like
this
this is a movie and so um i was gonna
stick to it until i
got it made now there were certainly
plenty of times where i was like oh this
is
never gonna happen i don't know how this
is ever gonna come together
um but um yeah i wasn't
i wasn't gonna stop
you know um i think that that's like
when you are in the low budget space and
you don't have access to all kinds of
money
or connections or whatever um you don't
have an agency that's backing you that's
gonna you know
find the money for you um
the one thing you have is your like your
perseverance or your stubbornness
because
nobody else your sisyphus is pushing the
rock up the hill
and nobody's to push it up with you so
you're just going to keep doing it and
it's going to roll back over on you a
bunch of times
um but that's that's the one commodity
that i could bring that would be the
thing that would um
ensure that the movie's gonna get made i
couldn't bring the money i couldn't
bring all the connections i couldn't
bring any of that stuff but i could
bring that
like i was just gonna keep pushing the
rock um
so yeah and then we ultimately were able
to do it we were ultimately able to put
the money together and
find some actors and shoot the film and
brian garrity
plays the protagonist yeah brian plays
his protagonist brian is um
brian's an extraordinary actor he's an
extraordinary actor it was um
i've worked with i've worked with good
actors before he's the best actor i've
ever worked with it was uh
it was kind of an amazing thing to watch
because he's a very
the character is the character's going
through really rough time and
it's a very quiet film it's a very and
he has to be so
so subtle but in that subtlety showing a
lot of pain
they're exhibiting a lot of pain and um
and brian
is funny and he's gregarious and he's
talkative and he's jokes and
he's a lot of fun on set and to watch
somebody
who can switch from that from joking
around
and playing and having a lot of fun to
all of a sudden he's in this moment with
a character who's having to go through
some grief a bunch of grief it's an
extraordinary thing to watch it's like
the greatest gift
to just be able to point your camera at
somebody who can do that
and do it so well it was it was
extraordinary
so you're in the editing phases of it
yeah the picture's locked but so we're
in color and sound
and everything yeah we're done cutting
so 10 years
10 years yeah yeah but it's not an
uncommon story
you know there's all kinds of people who
have that story if it took me you know
seven
eight nine ten years to finally get a
movie made i mean it was going on a long
time and
and um you know at one point you know i
realized
from the documentary until i don't know
i was probably a couple years into my
relationship with mike as we're
you know rewriting the film and and but
i'm still feeling like are
we going to be able to make this and i
look up and go wow i haven't made
anything
i haven't made anything it had been i
don't know four or
five years that i hadn't you know
actually directed i'd just written stuff
you know
and so then i just started making shorts
again like i have to
keep learning like to keep trying to
become a better filmmaker if i'm gonna
make a feature film i need to make more
films
um and so i made uh i made a series of
shorts over the course of three years
and that was really um it was really
great
for me it's like get back into the um
get back into the habit of making stuff
and
um get better
at it um i i think
you know you ask this question about
your film watcher or filmmaker
one of the things that i think that for
me um
makes me want to keep doing it is it
feels like a nut that i could never
quite
crack is it so there's so much to do
it's so hard to make
to make something that's really good
that really flies it's a i'm
never going to quite get this right and
so you're just i'm just going to keep
trying to get it right
um and so doing it over and over again
you know just in short form like
i remember somebody said that too oh i'm
done with short films when i was younger
somebody said that to me i'm done with
short films i'm going onto a feature and
i thought well yeah that's true we
should you should just move on you
should graduate and now like no
like just whatever you can make if you
can just make youtube videos make
youtube videos because you'll learn
doing that
um you know after we finish this thing
you know i've got a couple of other
um bigger things that i'd like to do but
then it's not well
maybe they would happen right away but i
kind of doubt it um
and if they don't i'll set up a couple
of shorts and
make some more shorts you know because
it'll i'll keep learning
by making um that's kind of the crucial
thing that i figured out while i was
doing that
your producer for faith has been with
you for how long
seven years is that is it going on eight
for a producer to stay that's pretty
committed yeah
yeah i think so i mean i think for the
life of a producer
you know it's it's different than than
being a director
and that they've got to have so many
balls in the air um
you know they can have 15 projects
all in various states and only a couple
of them are going to go
you know and so for for him
i mean i think that the um you know the
the first
couple years is just about rewriting it
and then trying to get some awareness
for the script um
and then from that trying to find cast
and raise money i mean but that's a
couple years process as well
it's funny i just saw brian i don't know
a couple months ago for
um adr and he was talking about a small
pride another small project he's trying
to do but he's like yeah four years
it'll take four years to get all the
money together or whatever
it's just this is not that much money
this is i'm gonna be a downer it's just
not this much that much money out in the
in the independent film space you know
especially for indie dramas which is
what mike produces and what i'm
interested in making these kind of art
arty dramas
um and so it's you're
you're you're competing with a lot of
people
for a very little very very little pie
piece of the pie um and so
it just it takes time but yeah he held
on he held on he really believed in the
project so i'm
i'm very grateful to him for that you
know and and because of his name because
he's known i mean
you know junebug i think at the time was
the was
the lowest budget movie to ever get
nominated for an oscar because amy adams
got nominated
for that movie um you know and his his
films have played
you know everywhere venice sundance
toronto
um and they've been nominated for
independent spirit awards and all that
sort of stuff so
his name being attached to the project
it's like that that's was very valuable
going forward um so yeah
do you share with your students the
process and how long it took
oh yeah are they surprised yeah no i'm
uh they know me for being uh
a realist like there's there's no like
uh
there's not like stars in our eyes kind
of kid this kind of thing it's like all
right kids this is the reality
this was 10 years and it was still hard
to raise the money
and i mean and i talked some of the some
of the stuff we were talking about in
terms of numbers you know i was talking
to them about like
the films that for instance have played
sundance that are going to be made for
or made for anywhere from a million to
five million dollars and they're mostly
getting if they get an offer
lots of them don't even get offers but
they get an offer they're 100 to 150
000 for for worldwide rights
you know and so um it
just to be i'm trying to be very
realistic with them so they understand
um but um
if you really want to do it you'll still
do it it's it's
i'm a very practical guy and so one of
the things we talk about quite a bit
the way i've set my life up is i have
this one thing
that pays my bills so i can do this
other thing
um and so if you can figure out a way it
doesn't have to be teaching and matter
of fact i wouldn't recommend
teaching because there's fewer and fewer
of these jobs out there
but if you can figure out a thing that
you don't hate
you don't have to love it but you don't
hate it
and it pays well enough to where you
know you can pay your bills pay your
rent pay your mortgage whatever
if you have kids they got new shoes on
their feet
and then you can sort of carve out time
to do this other thing whether it's
directing your own features or shooting
you know you want to be lots of students
want to be dp i would say that's
probably more popular than
even directing oh wow um i like the gear
they like the camera they wanna they
wanna
play with the play with the tools the
toys
um that's kind of what i talk to them
about is
is facing that reality
because how many kids are in film school
all around the country are all around
the world who all want to do
the same thing um and so you've got to
figure out how you're going to survive
first and then you can
sort of navigate your way into that
whatever you whatever avenue you want to
go whether it's writing directing
screenwriting dp editing whatever
do a lot of the students say well so and
so put their first movie on a credit
card or whatever so
they you know what i i at other schools
they probably do here it's not a thing i
mean yeah
like well we i come out of the
generation
of of you know kevin smith like kevin
smith does this thing with clerks and
it's all credit cards and
and then his career sort of blows up so
there were a lot i never did that
but there were a lot of people of my
generation who did do that
you know and to not as much success as
as
they just had a lot of debt uh and not a
huge blossoming career um so no they
i don't hear that much i mean i will say
that i give them the
the like um if i was a film student
now um what um
what i would probably do is i would um
i don't know if i would form a company
but you know find two other people
who are different than me so if i'm the
writer director
i'd find somebody who's really good with
a camera and maybe somebody who's good
at post or somebody who's good as a kind
of
producer he doesn't mind calling people
out of the blue and asking for stuff for
free
somebody like that and
form our own little group or whatever
and decide you know
we want to do three to five things over
the next
year to two years whether they be three
short films or a short film in two
commercials or some music videos or
whatever
and figure out how much that's going to
cost um
how much i shouldn't even say how much
can it cost how much can you put
together
so can all three of you save a hundred
bucks a month
so if all three of you are saving a
hundred bucks a month now all of a
sudden
you got about almost four thousand
dollars you get about 3 600
of each one of you puts together 100
puts puts away 100 bucks a month
and can all three of you put a thousand
dollars on a credit card thousand
dollars in debt
it's not horrible so if they all three
of them could put a thousand dollars on
a credit card without killing themselves
now all of a sudden you got
almost seven thousand dollars then can
all three of you start a crowdfunding
campaign where you raise
twenty five hundred dollars so with that
you got about ten grand
they're close to it what can you do for
ten thousand dollars
you know the three of you can you guys
come up with again
three ideas five ideas all of them have
to be small i would not recommend that
they make a feature film i know those
people who make feature films for ten
thousand dollars
maybe if it's your third or fourth movie
i would not do it for my first but
some people could do i'm not i can i
cannot do it i could not make anything
that is any good for ten thousand dollar
feature film for ten thousand dollars i
don't
what chloe zao did with the writer for
fifty thousand dollars to me is amazing
did you see the writer
no i wanted to beautiful movie it's all
the trailers
fifty thousand it's unbelievable but so
anyway that
that like that is a plan where
they're not going hugely in debt there's
a little bit of debt and if they can't
do the debt then they don't do the debt
you just do the savings and the
crowdfunding and then you get
six grand or something like that right
okay what can we do for six thousand
dollars
um and it allows them to make stuff
they don't need anybody's permission
it's just the three of them or the four
of them
they're doing the stuff that they're
interested in they're getting better at
it
and maybe one of those things gets them
a little attention to do something
bigger
probably not a film for marvel but maybe
a local commercial for somebody who has
a little bigger budget and they can do
something more
or a bigger music video or a bigger
short film or whatever
some sort of branded content for
somebody um
that would be the process that i would
go through if i was a student now
coming out and i this is by the way none
of this is
there are people who are doing this all
over the place now so i'm not
this is not some uh panda padded pant
i have no patent on this patented idea
um but it's a smart way to go about it
without weight because what most of us
do when we get out of film school is we
all right i'm just gonna wait for
somebody to
call me and offer me all kinds of money
to do something and that never happens
alexander payne is like the only person
i know that that happened for
because everybody loved his graduate
thesis film
is there any way you could have green
lit faith any earlier
probably not no maybe because it's
there's um well yeah if i
made it for less money if we made the
movie for
ten thousand dollars sure but i couldn't
have made the movie um
you know like um i think there's
there's some people well yeah what'd i
say
i i had a friend of mine say that to me
at one point probably three or four
years ago why don't you just you know
try to do it now for
fifty thousand dollars or something like
that which i didn't i don't
couldn't have put together 50 000 even
if i wanted to at that time
um but i had said well i want to give it
its best chance
um you know to make it at a level
where um it has a better chance of sort
of getting out into the world
and people seeing it and responding to
it now that still may not happen
and um since we didn't make it for we
made it for more than fifty thousand
dollars but
not a ton more well a little bit more
but anyway
um so i mean
i could always green let it green light
it myself
if i was gonna make it for super super
cheap um
but i needed some outside money in order
to make it at a level
and we still had to make it at a smaller
level than originally intended
you know we were supposed to shoot in
may of last year and the money fell out
you know to make it at a certain level
and the money fell
out two weeks before we were supposed to
shoot again this is not an uncommon
story this happens to
so many people um even much bigger films
than ours
which it was a devastating thing
but after i got over that we sort of
picked ourselves up and i had to
rewrite the film to be smaller so that
we could make it a level that we knew we
could get that amount of money for
um and so that's what we did you know
you were asking about limitations i mean
there's a limitation right there we had
a movie that was budgeted
needed to be made at this level we
couldn't get that money at that level we
could get the money at this level so
then we wrote a movie that or i rewrote
the movie so it fit that budget level
and to do it for fifty thousand dollars
it would have been a different level i
mean
the cost of making a movie just um
the labor alone you know what what it
means when you're
getting in those budget levels at 50 000
or
you know eliza hitman's first film it
felt like love which i think she made
for like 20 grand or something like that
it's a beautiful movie just like one of
those things like the writer
both of them are getting bigger budgets
and they deserve them
because to be able to do what they did
with the limited amount of money they
both deserve
they both deserve bigger budgets and be
trusted with them
because they clearly know what they're
doing um but
like um just to labor
when you're going down to 50 000 or
twenty thousand dollars or whatever
it just means you have less and less
people working on the movie
your camera team is one person you know
you have a camera person a sound person
and
maybe one other person and that's it um
and so
it's really really hard to make a movie
in that circum those circumstances and
there's no way i could have made this
movie
under those circumstances um so
i had to make it at a certain level i
could get it down to this level i
couldn't go any farther
were you cutting out locations or
certain characters yeah i carry
i had to cut when i went from the the
version that was supposed to exist in
may
it was cutting down locations and
cutting down characters but it was not
cutting
it was all extraneous it was stuff that
was not central to
um the story or more important to me was
the
the themes uh that stuff if i can keep
the the the themes of the story
um that stuff doesn't get weakened then
i can find a way to do it
uh that was the most important stuff uh
important thing to me but yeah so it's
it's always the thing like can you know
what's the thing i teach my students
two people in a room that's cheap to do
you know if you can keep your and
they're in the same room you keep two
people in a room
like that's that's the way to do
low-budget filmmaking once you
add more rooms and add more people it
gets much more expensive
and when you talk to your students about
sort of shrinking it down
and still having an effective story how
do they feel about that because so many
people they just
like they say they want to do
transformers first yeah they hate it
they everybody hates it nobody i didn't
i hated it when i had to shrink the
story i hated it but um if you're gonna
make the movie you gotta make the movie
um with what you have um yeah no they
hate it
like but it's part of the process like
you gotta learn
like because what if you
if they don't if i just let them go if i
didn't tell them that they had to shrink
something down or it's not going to be
physically
possible then when the trump's actually
shooting it that's when they figure it
out
that the oh i can't really do this and
then by then it's too late
and then it's way too late so but
sometimes they have to go through that
process of
you know they don't know what it's you
don't know what it's like until you've
done it there's
nothing that prepares you for filmmaking
there's nothing like it and it's the
only the only way you can practice
filmmaking is
by making something it's just the only
way you can learn about it
did the one budget fall apart over a
weekend
or uh we felt it coming
but we thought we were gonna get saved i
mean you're hoping against hope
that you're gonna get saved but then
ultimately we got the message that nope
not gonna happen so then that was so it
wasn't over
a weekend but there was just this like
final
nail in the coffin thing that was brutal
and so
this had been seven years at that point
yeah something like that sure
okay and then how are you dealing with
that emotionally knowing that
okay you're gonna have to probably take
people out of the film
take locations out yeah tear it down i
mean that that was
that was brutal i mean it's all these
calls or emails that you got to send i
mean i had cast all those smaller parts
um with a bunch of actors you know
around here
around la um and i had oh sorry
you're the part's not i had to cut your
part and they all understood i mean the
actors were all
great about that um i mean
that was like a death so when the money
falls out that was like a death
like it was literally because i could
not when it first happened i could not
see a way to actually get the movie made
um so there was a grieving process with
that it's just like i had to grieve for
a couple days but then it was um again i
go back to i'm
i'm stubborn as all hell and now i'm
making this movie
so once i got over the fact that that
that this kind of death had happened and
that i then had to still figure out a
way to make it then it just becomes
about
figuring out a way to make it then it
again it gets to that question
like it's a problem that i've got to
solve it's a nut that i've gotta crack
so how can i do it how can i
how can i do this at a level that's
smaller
and so it's just figuring out those
mechanics and it meant
cutting locations cutting actors but
once i saw what i was doing and that it
was not affecting
um all of the central stuff in the movie
the central parts of the story the
central ideas of the story like
and what the main character is going
through all of that stuff is still there
then i was fine it's like oh i can do
this like i can still make this like
this other stuff that i had
it was it was not necessary so
we don't need that extra money i can't
get that extra money anyway so why have
it
um it would have made the movie fuller
but it it would not it does not change
the movie does not change the core of
the movie
so once i had gone through the the the
sort of
you know as i said grieving process of
it then it's
just about okay now i'm still climbing
this mountain it's that stubbornness
of i'm not i'm not giving up on i'm
gonna make this thing well it's almost a
parallel to what the story's about
in some sense um
hmm i don't know i've never thought of
it that way um
i it's just more of um
i'll tell you what it was one of the
like what lessons do you learn
you learn for me or what i learn i
learned that i will
even with all i mean mike mike ryan or
my producer my other producer sherry
hefner
they're great i could not have done the
film without them
but ultimately when you're making a
movie
you are the reason that it's going to
ultimately get made because you're going
to be the one who's going to fight the
hardest for it
other people will fight for it you will
fight the hardest for it
if i'd has said that's it
you know when that when the money fell
out if i'm the one if i go i give up
i'm not going to be able to do it you
know they want to try to talk me in for
a little bit but they've got other stuff
that they're doing too again that's the
life of the producer you got 15 things
going
some of them don't go and if the if the
director
the writer director stops oh okay i'm
just going to move over
again they're not callous they're not
being uh insensitive or anything they
got other stuff that they got to do
so that uh that was one of the main
lessons like
you're gonna be the driving the main
driving force
always um on this sort of stuff
i'm not sure whose statistic this is but
99 of filmmakers never go on to make
another feature film
do you have another one in you i know
you're still you're still wrapping this
one up yeah i do
yeah i've got multiple things that are
um written
um but you know that doesn't mean that
they're gonna happen i mean it's just
it's it's hard it's really hard to get a
movie made
um you know if i don't make another
feature i'll make more stuff i'll make
more shorts
but i like i
don't suffer for um
ideas um which again that sounds really
arrogant for me to say that
but um i um
i feel like there's stuff that
um stuff that i want to make
stuff that i think is um
interesting stuff that i think i have a
a unique perspective on that i want to
try to get at um
and so and i don't know you're just
alive
for it like when you want to do it
and i enjoy writing like i enjoy that
part of the process
um and so when you're when you're um
when you want to do it like you're
looking for things
that are going to help you create like
um
something for a film an idea or a
texture or whatever
and so you're kind of open to it and
looking so
stuff sort of gets you fired up like an
idea
or a moment or whatever and see what you
can generate from that but yeah no i
have
i have two things written that um
i'd want to rewrite but yeah i'd be
ready to make
where are you finding time to write i
mean you have such a full life
all these responsibilities well but like
but that it's
when you enjoy it you find the time for
it
and i didn't write them last weekend you
know i wrote uh the first drafts of
those a couple years ago
you know um so but when you
when it's when it's you're getting
something out of it
you don't it doesn't feel like a um it
doesn't feel like a task
and i mean again this is the this is the
advantage of being a teacher
and having my summers off and um i can
spend time on that sort of stuff
and um it's good
so you never the well never runs drive
no there's wow curse okay no there's a
curse
no i mean like i larger ideas certainly
or things
like worlds that i'd like to go into um
social like yeah i'm i'm really
interested in things
like social class and economics and
certain things about um certain contexts
and certain aspects of like american
identity
i'm really interested in that sort of
stuff right and so
it's like oh it'd be interesting to make
a movie about that or a story that's
focused on that
but i'm like everybody else like you
know oh i've got
uh six pages here now what the hell do i
do you know i'm like
the the well very often runs dry or
the well is very often full with crappy
ideas
so um but i do
feel like um
i do feel like that that that's a
resource
uh i don't like it's it's not even i
shouldn't even say that i don't
want for ideas i guess i'm always
searching for ideas maybe that's a
better way to say it i'm always looking
for stuff to write because once i find
something that
that sparks me that's exciting and
you're trying to get that feeling
always i think um it's an intoxicating
thing
it's like a high you know it's a good
idea and you write it down
it's a good scene it was the one of the
ones that i'm talking about that i
would like to make next like i just the
other day
one good thing about driving home from
santa monica for two hours
is that you get ideas yeah yeah but
but i i was me alone in the car and like
oh
there's a good idea i could do that in
that script
and that's um that is intoxicating
like that's a great feeling it's like
you get that excitement for the thing
because it's you know you
you the excitement can wane you know
with an idea
and then all of a sudden you get a new
idea and you oh that's right i gotta
crack that back
open and get back into that um i don't
know i think you
always be seeking that that feeling you
know
it was interesting to see like humphrey
bogart he either plays like a
a screenwriter that hasn't had a hit in
years or he would play you know a
detective of course but um
just just oh you're a screenwriter you
know and it sounds so glamorous and then
you see like it's definitely difficult
for him and sort of this downtrodden
you know mindset but having to like keep
himself revived i don't know it's just
i love seeing um films about
screenwriters oh yeah adaptation
sunset boulevard is just exquisite that
the
um oh god what is his name
oh my god well whatever what's that
yeah it's billy wilder filming i'm
trying to think the actor's name anyway
you know he's the
the uh collection agencies are calling
they're
trying to tow his car he just can't pay
his rent but then he meets this
yeah but but that depiction
of the screenwriter which is so very
honest
um yeah i always loved that right and
also to uh
in a lonely place with humphrey bogart
oh and just you know
his life seems very organized and then
um i don't want to give it away if
anyone's seen it even though
so someone told me that if a movie is
older than 30 years i guess you can give
spoilers oh i spoil stuff all the time
in class that's half my job is spoiling
the movie
but you know he's he's accused of this
crime and and
um you just you know these women are so
intrigued because he's this screenwriter
or whatever and
um and he has a number of things that
have gotten him into trouble
i don't know where i'm going with it but
i just find it uh
i don't know it seems glamorous but it
it's right it's probably
when you're in horrible la traffic that
spark of
it's not sitting at this typewriter you
know with
sort of the in this immaculate
apartment as humphrey bogart was seen in
a lonely place that this
these ideas are coming it's in those
kind of moments where you want to check
out
yeah that's where it's coming yeah but i
mean i think it's also like we're our
projections of everything like we want
to project well all them
you know because um their life is
probably better than mine
because they get to do this or they're
doing that and they don't
nah everybody's life is essentially the
same
like there is the drudgery of everything
the drudgery of screenwriting the
drudgery of teaching
the drudgery of working customer service
the treasury of whatever
um it's all the same and there's there's
you know for 99.9 of the people of it
there is
little to no glamour there's no glamour
in it and it's
um um but
the the one thing the advantage
of this because it is it's filled with
all that stress it's filled with
very little to no validation for your
work i mean that's the other thing about
being a filmmaker is
no one may ever care about what you're
doing
um and so you got to sort of accept that
um or a very small number of people may
ever care
um but um like
the the advantage of it is for the most
part
i don't we wouldn't do it if we didn't
really
love the thing because it's so hard to
do
and there can be no validation for it at
the end of it
so you have to enjoy it you have to
enjoy the process i wrote a
i wrote a little thing where you were
talking about the the seed and spark
um i wrote a thing for um filmmaker
magazine while i was doing that
just like a little uh post for their
online
um anyway and and
the the gist of it was is that the
the dream of making a the movie or dream
of doing this
is not about any kind of success however
you're going to define that
but it's really about the making because
that's the thing that's the most
pleasurable
like is is the the making is the you
know finding the
finding the right frame finding the
right cut finding the right piece of
music finding the right
dialogue watching brian garrity and a
close-up and going oh my god this guy is
just such a good actor or whatever it's
that stuff that's going to be the thing
that um
that lasts the other stuff will not last
so
that's the dream of it at least to me at
what point did you approach
brian garrity to be the protagonist in
faith uh
so we uh so when that whole thing
happened
and when we lost the money we had other
actors attached
uh and another actor attached to that
the lead part chris
um and another a different actor
attached for the pastor
and those guys are great guys and i love
them and they have been attached for
almost a year
to play the parts and so i had again
another part of this these horrible
phone calls and i have to call them and
tell them that the money's falling out
and they were both so disappointed they
felt so bad for me they're just there's
they're good people they're sweet guys
and they were both
willing to um stay on because i said
look i'm gonna
i'm gonna try like hell to still make
this movie
and they say hey as long as we can make
the schedules work we'll do it
um but then of course we couldn't make
the schedules work one of them um
one of them had a big tv show and the
other one was a lead in a broadway play
right when we were shooting the movie
and so it just didn't work and
so then it's a scramble like okay how do
we um
how do we replace these guys who were
you know
not not huge stars but like known actors
and really really good actors
and so um
brian garrity was suggested to me and a
friend of a friend
was able to get him to the script and he
read it
and he liked it and um he was available
like he'd been doing that show the
alienness to the tnt
thing but then he was off and he didn't
have anything again until
i don't remember what whatever the
schedule worked and
uh so we met and we got along and
and um he could see what i was trying to
do and i could see how he fit in the
part
and um yeah it was good you know
it's just luck there's a lot of luck so
you know that happens here too we just
happened to know somebody who could get
in the script and he fit and
and he was um known enough to where we
could hold on i mean this is
this is the kind of cynical part of this
business but he's
um known enough to where we could hold
on to some money you know
the hurt locker and boardwalk empire
chicago pd
all this stuff it means something for um
financing obviously so yeah
what's your first week working on a new
idea like like what are you
if you've gotten this idea while you're
in traffic or wherever it is standing
line at the supermarket
but then you're actually okay i'm going
to invest time in this what's it like
uh it's just notes so i'm very organized
disorganized um it's it's
it's a notebook where i am just
i'm writing either lines of dialogue
ideas for
seeing something about a character
character breakdown
any number of things that i think or a
theme
something that i want somebody to say i
don't even know what character would say
it but this is a line that i want
something where it's happening um it's
that it's a bunch of that i don't do the
note card thing i don't i will i will
write a series of notes i might even
from those notes like i'll fill up one
of those
like those black i don't know if i have
any of those black notebooks you know
the things that
in seven where the guy used to make all
his notes right one of those
i'll fill one of those up and i might
write a draft out of that that draft
will suck
but i have something and then i might
then make an outline from the draft
so i've got notes that i turn into a
draft that i will then turn into an
outline defined structure i don't like
to
structure first because i'm not as
interested in plot i'm
i'm really not that interested in plot
at all i'm much more interested
in character and theme and so it's about
um
ideas and how i'm trying to express
those ideas whether it's through
characters actions or their context or
whatever um and so i found that if i try
to impose structure first which is what
i think of as outline
being is a structural thing that then i
get too focused on the mechanics of plot
which i
don't care about at all i want it to be
about
character and characters journey however
you want to describe it
so that's why outline actually comes for
me
after i've written a draft so that i can
then okay here are all these ideas
are there a way i can structure these
ideas now
okay if that makes sense so it's not an
efficient way
like if i was like on for hire for a
script i probably couldn't do it that
way but i'm
nobody's knocking on my door to do that
pay me a bunch of money to write a
script for them
so this way allows me to um
to hold on to the things that i think
are more important because if i'm
worried about
these kind of story beats and steps and
because american movies are all about
causality this causes this causes this
causes this
then i might lose the character because
if the character is doing things
that are contradictory there's not a
clear causality between
them that might be way more interesting
than if there is
um so that's kind of way whether that
happens over a week i don't know i've
got two kids now who the hell knows
how long it'll take me to get to those
places it might get me i might get to a
draft in a week but i kind of doubt it
um that first week is probably just
going to be notes notes notes notes
notes
and trying to figure out who it is and
then when you actually get a first draft
down
are you doing the sort of putting it
away and then looking at it again
yeah that's generally what i found is
the best
thing it's um i want to i want to look
at it with fresh eyes
i'm not sending it to anybody yet
because it's not good enough yet
you don't want to waste people's time
and i don't want to get a bunch of notes
from
i don't waste their time and i also
don't want to get a bunch of notes for
stuff that i'll
of course i know what's wrong with it
right after i look at it a second time
um so it's don't look at it for
whatever a couple weeks a month
something like that
um and then go back in and look at it
and um
hopefully do a pretty significant
teardown
of it um pieces of it will survive but
it should be a pretty significant
teardown because the first thing
shouldn't be very good it should
um you're trying to get some ideas out
uh
you're trying to work around those ideas
but um
it's not gonna be anywhere near what the
finished product i mean that first draft
of faith from 10 years ago was
vastly different than the thing the
movie that we shot
you still have it yeah somewhere it's on
a thumb drive somewhere
yeah where did you write it
i did the uh the very cliched thing
this was before i had kids so i could do
this as i i
uh went to i went up the coast and i
just rented a hotel for like two or
three days and
banged out the first draft i mean i had
a whole bunch of it sort of worked out
so it wasn't like a
what's my idea and three days later i
had to finish draft of the script i had
a whole bunch of notes and stuff that i
was working from but yeah
did you see it like an ocean view hotel
uh
no i don't i didn't have the money to
afford that but it was by the ocean here
oh it sounds so romantic yeah yeah yeah
i know i did that
so but yeah good luck me convincing my
wife to let me do that again now
leave her with two kids so i can go
right i don't think that's gonna happen
did you do it with a laptop or did you
get right in yeah no yeah i'm i'm too
lazy
i'm too lazy to do long form i've uh
that was one thing that like i had final
draft
very early on when i was still an
undergrad and i've just gotten used to
writing that way
was the was going back to that 10-year
hotel stay was that
taking clock worth it in terms of it
actually got you to finish it because
you're like i'm here i paid for this
yeah i know it helped but that that
it helped i'm sure i can't remember it
so long ago
um but it was also like it was good to
just
um that was just the thing i was there
to do
it was just that you know nothing else
um it was a good feeling and also the
the idea
felt like you have times when you're
reaching for the idea like you're you're
writing and but you're still reaching
for the idea
the idea was like close enough to where
i could do it in
that three days time you know get it out
there's other scripts or
the idea is not close enough to where i
wouldn't be able to get it all out in
three days time
if that makes any sense it does yeah
that's interesting
how many drafts of faith did you write
before you sent it to your producer
mike i had probably written
three maybe four something like that
i want to say i'd have to go back and
look but i want to say it was three or
four drafts
and it's a yeah like i said it's a
vastly different script than the one
um that we ended up shooting that
thematically it's the same uh
structurally and character-wise it's a
little bit different
so three or four drafts in you send it
to him
what's his time frame for getting back
to you what were the notes uh
he got back to me probably within
three weeks something like that
again i won't make it sound like i just
sent it to him like
there was plenty of people i sent it to
who didn't respond um but it was kind of
in his wheelhouse like it's
he was he told me when he was like 14 he
was thinking about being a priest
oh wow um but then girls
and so then you know girls happen to be
yeah exactly
um and um
his his response i mean he responded the
script he said
i like the way it's dealing with these
kinds of um
with issue these kinds of issues but no
judgment to the characters
um and then he had a few ideas for
the ending as i recall or i don't know
so then we
we talked on the phone about it and um
he suggested i do another like scene
outline so i did a scene outline and
then he came out to la because
he was here he's a new york based
producer
he was here because one of his films was
i was around the independent spirit
awards i remember that
and one of his films was nominated for i
think was one of the actors or something
and so then we got to meet and talk face
to face and he
suggested a big change i originally the
story was
actually divided between two characters
who's two different stories going on and
he suggested just to
simplify it to just focus on one
character for a number of reasons he
said don't change
the the again it's the themes
the ideas all that stuff stays the same
you just got to simplify the story so
it's just
one person's story um so i did that
and he was he responded really
positively to that rewrite
and so then we were kind of off and
running in terms of
then trying to generate interest we
ended up out i ended up out in new york
through
with ifp they had a
this kind of screenplay what did they
call it
this program that's emergency emerging
storytellers
where they selected it was a pretty
competitive program they only select x
number of scripts and then we got to
meet
uh with like sony classics and
i don't remember a bunch of different
companies you know trying to generate
interest see if you can get any money we
didn't get any money
um but uh but it was a really good thing
and and um and then it was i
rewrote a couple more drafts and then
eventually we got there do you think the
themes
in faith are ones that people can relate
to
even if they're you know
non-denominational they're not part of a
church
even if they don't consider themselves
religious yeah i mean i think
i i think the audience for it will
probably
be more people who consider themselves
agnostic
um more so than well i don't know
god sorry sorry um
i think the audience four will probably
be people who consider themselves
uh agnostic i mean i don't know we there
might be some
um some regular church goers who
who are interested in it too um
but yeah i mean especially people who
maybe went to church
as um when they were kids and now aren't
as connected to it
um i think they probably will respond to
it um
but we'll see i don't know i mean that's
a big thing now is like you uh you're
supposed to
figure out who your audience is
beforehand right
i'm not i'm not as comfortable with that
uh just because i feel like you're um
i want to make the thing
i want to make the thing that's in my
head that i think is interesting without
[Music]
thinking about who else is going to find
it interesting
not because i don't think or don't want
anybody else to find it interesting
but i'm too i'm worried that if i focus
too much on what other people are
thinking about it
then i'll lose the thread of what's
interesting about it to me
the hope is that if it's interesting to
me it's going to be interesting
to other people if we do it well enough
and that will hopefully be enough
to get in a big enough audience to um
make the movie worthwhile
um but who knows um i just i
like the i know several people who are
sort of involved in this like marketing
and distribution
before you make the movie and i
understand it
because of these things we've been
talking about in terms of the lack of
funding and trying to
get your money back from a movie i
completely understand it but just as a
as the writer director in me is like
i can't think about that stuff or else
all of a sudden you're worried about
this choice and how it fits in the film
you're not worried about if it fits in
the
the the world of the film you're worried
about how other people are going to
respond to it and i just
i it's anathema to me i just i can't
i don't want to do it so i don't know
we'll see
you know you you uh you hope you hope
that you've done something that enough
people will respond to because there's
you know people have um
put their faith in you and and um put
some money behind the movie and
and so um you don't want to disappoint
him you wanted to
you want that faith to be rewarded
so here's hoping